des dizaines de soldats progressent en
colonne sur les routes du tigré sur ces
images de la télévision éthiopienne
l'armée fédérale semble prendre peu à
peu le contrôle de cette région
dissidente du nord du pays une zone où
de violents combats se déroulent depuis
le début du mois contre les forces du
front de libération du peuple du tigré
sur twitter le premier ministre assure
que l'armée a repris le contrôle de
mekele la capitale de la région
le gouvernement fédéral a maintenant
pris le contrôle total de la ville de
mekele cela marque l'accomplissement de
la phase finale de l'opération militaire
l'armée mène l'opération avec la
précision et le soin nécessaires pour
s'assurer que les civils ne sont pas
ciblés
la prise de contrôle de mekele a
également été annoncée par le chef
d'état major de l'armée
mais ses déclarations restent
difficilement vérifiables car les
communications du tigre y ont été
coupées par addis abeba jeudi dernier le
premier ministre éthiopien habib ahmed a
ordonné à ses forces d'enclencher la
dernière phase de l'opération militaire
et une offensive menée à l'aide de
l'aviation et de l'artillerie
sans cesser de combattre les autorités
tigréenne ont appelé la communauté
internationale à condamner des attaques
commises contre les civils et les
infrastructures même si aucun chiffre
officiel n'est disponible
ce conflit aurait fait plusieurs
milliers de victimes selon des ong
les combats ont également entraîné un
afflux de réfugiés vers le soudan voisin
selon l'onu plus de 43000 éthiopien y
serez accueillis dans des camps
rudimentaire nous avons vu le nombre de
réfugiés diminué mais leur afflux
continu 500 à 600 personnes par jour ce
n'est pas un petit chiffre ne nous
trouvons pas il est vrai qu'il ya eu des
jours où ils affluaient par milliers
mais cela dépend aussi de la difficulté
de se déplacer dans leur pays et à la
frontière pour tenter de trouver une
issue politique à la crise l'union
africaine a lancé une médiation menée
par les ancien président du mozambique
du liberia et de l'afrique du sud après
les avoir rencontré le premier ministre
éthiopien a annoncé la mise en place
d'un corridor humanitaire dans le tigré
sans donner plus de précisions